hier hast du das einzige
biskuitbodenrezept was du brauchst
trenne Eiweiß von Eigelb Schlag das
Eiweiß mit einer Prise Salz auf gib die
Hälfte des Zuckers mit dazu und dann
entsteht so eine bmasse in einer anderen
Schüssel Eigelb mit restlichem Zucker
und Vanilleextrakt dickcremig schlagen
dann die bmasse behutsam unterrühren
mehlstärke und Backpulver hinzusieben
versucht keine Luft rauszuschlagen und
macht das wirklich mit ganz viel Liebe
ob ihr einen Tortenring oder eine
Springform verwendet ist komplett euch
überlassen streicht den Teig aber noch
schön glatt und gebt ih dann in den
vorgeheizten backof nach dem Backen mit
dem backformlöser den Tortenboden
befreien durchschneiden und beliebig
weiter verarbeiten dieses Rezept habe
ich vor 16 Jahren experimentiert und
mache es seitdem nicht anders er ist
richtig luftig und bleibt bis zu vier
Tage frisch